klima kabinett auf der zielgeraden durch
ein milliardenschweres maßnahmenpaket
mir die große koalition den klimaschutz
verbessern
streit ums öl für den angriff auf eine
saudische raffinerie machen die usa den
iran verantwortlich der streitet alles
ab und so jubeln weltmeister spaniens
basketballer gewinnen das finale gegen
argentinien und blumen sich mit
einzubringen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara vinken abend und ein herzliches
willkommen norbert könig ist auch dabei
für den sport guten namen
was kommt mit dem klimaschutz paket der
bundesregierung auf uns zu kosten von 40
milliarden euro hieß es heute in
verschiedenen medien in fünf tagen will
die koalition maßnahmen vorstellen um
den co2 ausstoß zu senken
bislang ist das kaum gelungen die
klimaziele für 2020 werden deutlich
verfehlt 40 prozent weniger co2 ausstoß
im vergleich zu 1990 das ist nicht mehr
zu schaffen
die neue marke 55 prozent bis 2030 über
den stand der verhandlungen christian
hübscher damit deutschland ein anderes
ein klimafreundliches landwirt plant die
große koalition offenbar unter anderem
diese maßnahmen höhere staatliche
prämien für elektro- oder hybridautos
abwrackprämien für alte ölheizungen und
bahnticket sollen günstiger werden durch
eine mehrwertsteuersenkung es geht vor
allem um anreize und es geht darum die
menschen ja auch mitzunehmen dass es
einen gesamten gesamtgesellschaftlichen
konsens gibt dass wir etwas tun müssen
und wenn wir über die frage der
bepreisung sprechen mit
marktwirtschaftlichen instrumenten und
unter berücksichtigung sozialer aspekte
dann wird es dazu natürlich vorgaben von
der politik geben
so wird die politik wohl zum beispiel
kurzstreckenflüge unattraktiver machen
durch eine höhere ticketsteuer
was genau die tonne co2 künftig kosten
soll darüber herrscht noch uneinigkeit
die union will jedenfalls an der
schwarzen null festhalten
in summe aber könnten all diese
klimaschutzmaßnahmen 40 milliarden euro
kosten
die fdp protestiert wir können nicht die
probleme des jahres 2040 bereits im jahr
2020 lösen
es geht auch um freie lebensweise es
geht auch um wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt das darf man nicht alles am
überhasteten klimaschutz der im zweifel
im weltmaßstab nichts bringt opfern eine
entscheidende woche für die koalition
vizekanzler scholz gibt sich in berlin
direkt interview optimistisch das sieht
alles danach aus dass wir das schaffen
können
ich spüre bei allen koalitionspartnern
den willen tatsächlich etwas
zustande zu bringen dass der größe der
aufgabe gerecht wird und das halte ich
auch für nötig der ökostromanteil in
deutschland soll bis 2030 bei 65 prozent
liegen für all diese klima wohltaten
will die regierung bis freitag ein
durchgerechnetes konzept haben das ganze
interview mit olaf scholz sehen sie im
anschluss bei berlin direkt
die usa der iran und jetzt ein neuer
tiefpunkt in ihren ohnehin schlechten
beziehungen der drohnenangriff auf
ölanlagen in saudi arabien
zwar haben sich dazu ausdrücklich
jemenitische husi rebellen bekannt aber
genauso ausdrücklich haben sich die usa
festgelegt nein das war der iran eine
explosive und komplizierte lage in der
golfregion ist dass iran steht hinter
den rebellen im jemenitischen
bürgerkrieg sei die arabien kämpft auf
der anderen seite mit den
regierungstruppen und ist gleichzeitig
mit den usa verbindet rauchfahnen zu
enorm dass sie von satelliten aus dem
weltall registriert werden
der größte öl komplex saudi arabiens
seit samstagfrüh in flammen das feuer
sei unter kontrolle so offizielle
quellen aber millionen fass rohöl können
wohl über längere zeit nicht exportiert
werden
es sei ein angriff mit ihren drohnen
über hunderte kilometer hinweg behaupten
rufe im jemen ein präziser
vergeltungsschlag für luftangriffe saudi
arabiens yahia sarria sprecher der who
sie berichtet von zehn drohnen mit denen
der angriff auf saudi arabien
durchgeführt wurde
für amerika ist iran urheber des
angriffs in einer twitter botschaft
erklärt der amerikanische außenminister
mike kompon unter anderem iran hat jetzt
einen beispiellosen angriff auf die
weltweite energieversorgung gestartet
für pompey keine vermutung sondern eine
tatsache
das amerikanische öl embargo gegen den
iran vor einem last offenbar teheran zu
aktionen gegen westliche öllieferungen
zunehmend wohnen hier waren versucht
sich zu wehren gegen die sanktionen und
das kann das asymmetrische stunden das
kann durch seine nadelstich politik den
usa zeigen dass es dass die usa ihre
eigenen verbündeten nicht schützen kann
es kann westlichen staaten anderen
westlichen staaten zeigen dass ölexporte
aus dem persischen golf schwierig werden
wenn ihre an seinem nicht exportieren
kann die who die haben weitere angriffe
gegen saudi arabien angekündigt im
sanitär 1 offenbar trotz
demonstrationsverbot zogen in hongkong
wieder zehntausende menschen der
demokratiebewegung durch die innenstadt
dabei kam es erneut zu gewalt einige
aktivisten warfen steine und
molotowcocktails
die polizei setzte tränengas und
wasserwerfer ein
tunesien ist das einzige land das nach
dem arabischen frühling 2011 echte
demokratische reformen eingeleitet hat
heute können sieben millionen tunesier
zum zweiten mal frei wählen
allerdings drückt die schlechte
wirtschaftslage die stimmung aus
tunesien berichtet christel hass der
tinten blaue fingerabdruck muss auf den
wahlzettel bevor er in die tonne
geworfen wird sonst ist er ungültig 26
kandidaten bewerben sich um die
präsidentschaft so viele wie noch nie
ich hoffe dass wir den richtigen wählen
einen der die demokratie stärkt ich
möchte dass das land vorankommt und dass
mehr jobs für die jungen leute gibt in
tunesien sind über 34 prozent der jungen
arbeitslos ein riesenproblem
die wirtschaft ist weiter in der krise
alles ist teurer geworden
unser geld ist nichts mehr wert wir
leben von der hand in den mund was
tunesien jetzt braucht sind
wirtschaftsreformen die greifen
wer auch immer der nächste präsident
wird er muss jobs schaffen und vertrauen
gewinnen denn viele tunesier sagen uns
wir haben zwar freiheit und demokratie
aber davon allein können wir nicht leben
einer der favoriten ist nabil karoui
eine art tunesischer berlusconi medien
mogul und außerdem noch wohltäter der
schwachen doch er sitzt wegen
angeblicher geldwäsche in
untersuchungshaft solange er nicht
verurteilt ist dafür antreten
viele tunesier aberglauben den
versprechungen der politik nicht mehr
das hat folgen bis zum nachmittag haben
nur 27,8 prozent an der wahl
teilgenommen
in frankfurt gab es auch heute wieder
proteste gegen die internationale
automobilausstellung mehrere hundert
demonstranten blockierten zwei eingänge
sie fordern klimafreundlichen verkehr
messebesucher wurden zu anderen
eingängen geleitet und jetzt norbert mit
glücklichen spanien ja und zwar weil sie
zum zweiten mal basketball weltmeister
sind 2006 hatten sie in japan den titel
geholt nun hat es in china geklappt für
die spanier mit einem klaren 95 zu 75
gegen argentinien sind sie nachfolger
der schwer enttäuschten us amerikaner
13 jahre nach dem triumph in japan sieht
spanien dem pekinger finale hochverdient
mit 95 zu 75 gegen argentinien das seit
der ersten wm 1950 den titel nicht mehr
holen konnte dabei gelingt es marc gasol
als zweitem spieler im selben jahr den
endlich dritter mit toronto zu holen und
weltmeister zu werden
argentinien mit spielmacher facundo
kampa zu kommt kaum zur geltung die
dreimaligen europameister dominieren die
partie dank einer starken teamleistung
für spanien ist es das fünfte gold bei
einem großereignis in den letzten 15
jahren vor dem endspiel hatte frankreich
wm bronze im kleinen finale gegen
australien geholt
weltrekord im halbmarathon der kenianer
geoffrey canmore verbessert in
kopenhagen die bisherige marke um 17
sekunden der dreimalige weltmeister
braucht für die 21 kilometer und 97
eineinhalb meter 58 minuten und eine
sekunde überraschende auswärtssieg für
den sc freiburg in der fußball
bundesliga die breisgauer klettern nach
dem 3 zu 0 in hoffenheim auf platz drei
der tabelle hinter leipzig und dortmund
und die fußball welt trauert um eine
trainer legende rudi gutendorf ist am
freitag im alter von 93 jahren gestorben
mit seiner defensiv strategie machte
sich gutendorf genannt riegel rudi in
der bundesliga einen namen später zog es
ihn hinaus in die weite welt des
fußballsports mit 55 trainerjobs in 32
ländern rund um den erdball im guinness
buch der rekorde von den bermudas bis
samoa ein liebenswerter weltbürger
herzlich verabschiedet das was vielen
dank fehlt noch der blick aufs wetter
nördlich von main und mosel regnet es
bei 15 bis 18 grad zeitweise an der see
ist es freundlicher im süden gibt es
örtlich nebel
später scheint aber oft die sonne und es
wird warm am oberrhein bis 28 grad
das war es von uns um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie christian sieh was im
heute-journal wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen richtig schönen sonntagabend und
bis machen wenn sie mögen